we swore we would do anything to protect
the last city some of us paid the
ultimate price I am all that remains
Destiny's rise of iron is almost here
and we were lucky enough to get some
hands-on time with the new Game of
Thrones inspired expansion and with new
expansions come new gear new raids and
new challenges this is rise of iron and
this is what we know let's talk about
weapons you guys like those right
existing weapons are being tweaked for
rise of irons released but you'll be
getting your hands on new stuff like the
flaming battle axe Occam's razor the
titanium orchid and the trespasser
sidearm in fact you can get the
trespasser in game right now of course
you can't have new weapons without new
armor and the maximum light level is
going up to 400 content from the taken
king and the base game won't be raised
like this but you'll still earn new
high-level gear by raising the rap of
factions like the house of judgement or
the Queen's rap you'll also earn a
unique armor set from the new game mode
archons Forge it's a horde style mode
with three tiers and a time limit almost
like a hybrid of Court of Oryx in prison
of elders new weapons new armor and a
new raid complete the trifecta rise of
iron's new raid is called wrath of the
machine it features the Fallen and it
drops three days after the expansion
itself rise of iron is also changing up
iron banner events and the first one
features supremacy another new mode with
a PvP focus floored Saladin is moving to
fell winter peak a brand-new area which
unfortunately means destiny players
without the expansion will be unable to
experience future iron banners of course
seasonal events like the festival of the
lost and the sparrow racing league will
also return fell winter peak will also
be the site of a new social space there
are new vendors offering gear and
bounties plus secret areas that only
unlock during special events and if your
friends want to play a little rougher in
PvP you can do that with rise of iron's
new private matches which are actually
live right now you can unload and
grimoire cards in these matches and
they're available for everyone not just
rise of iron players and with all of
this content you'll need a way
to track everything finishing certain
objectives and rise of iron will level
up a special new book and earn you some
sweet rewards like armor upgrades
shaders and ships rise of iron will be
launching exclusively for ps4 and xbox
one on September 20th you can download
it standalone for thirty bucks or grab
the sixty dollar collection that
includes destiny and all of its previous
expansions you'll also get a handy
booster to take your character to level
40 and 280 light it's a great way to try
out a new character and prepare yourself
for rise of iron's launch for even more
gameplay tips and tricks head over to
gamespot see you in orbit guardian